بالاضافه الى ذلك فاننا على استعداد من
موقعنا
لزياده وجودنا والوصول الى الاشخاص الذين
هم بحاجه الى مساعده هذه مساله لكن من هذا
الجانب فاننا نعمل
مع كافه المحافظات سعيا لوجود منافذ دخولي
الى الشمال الغربي
وبالاضافه الى ذلك فاننا نعمل
قريبا على ان على ان نضمن ان هذه
الامدادات التي قدمناها كما تعلمون سوف
سوف تنتهي
وهناك مخازن في دبي تحتوي على بعض المعدات
الطارئه
والمؤن الضروريه التي لابد من ايصالها الى
هناك واعمل ما امله هو انه لمره واحده
ان يجعل كافه الاطراف مصلحه الشعب تتغلب
على كافه المصالح الاخرى وخاصه ان الكل
يطالب بالعون واهيبوا بكافه الشركاء ان
يعملوا على تسهيل
هذه المساله بصرف النظر عن كافه الضغوط
لان الامر يتعلق بالشعب اننا مستعدون في
مساله
تقديم المؤن التي قد تستغرق بضعه ايام
لوصولها لكافه المناطق ونعلم على زياده
المؤن والامدادات
ولكننا بحاجه الى مزيد من الدعم اود ان
اقول مساله اخرى ان الارقام لم يتم ذكرها
ما نحتاجه قد يكون اقل مما يرد الحديث عنه
اسمعوا اسمعوا البعض يتحدثوا عن ارقام قد
تصل خمسه اضعاف ما قد نحتاجه بصوره فعليه
لابد لنا من اجراء تقييم فعلي وحقيقي
للاحتياجات ولابد لنا من ان
نعالج كافه هذه المسائل في سياق
في سياق معاناتنا مع كافه المشاكل العلقه
الاخرى سؤال ايضا
تابع هل لك ان تذاكرنا ما هي التحديات
التي واجهتكم في مساله تامين الامدادات
عبر الخطوط والحدود بحيث يتم
بحيث يتم تامينها عبر كافه المنافذ
دعيني اجيب على هذا السؤال
في في غضون الاشهر السبع
السبعه او ثمانيه الماضيه استطعنا ان نؤمن
امدادات
عبر الخطوط
وبمغدورنا فعل
بمقدورنا تاميني المزيد منها لكن هناك
احتياجات لابد من معالجتها ومقدور زياده
حجم القافلات من اربعه عشر او خمسه عشر
شاحنه الى اعداد اكبر اننا جاهزون لكننا
بانتظار كافه الشركاء لتسهيل هذا الامر
الحكومه هي المشكله
لم اقل هذا لم اقل ان الحكومه هي المشكله
الحكومه وما تقوله بان لديها كافه
التسهيلات
وكنا قد حصلنا على بعض خطابات التسهيل من
قبل الحكومه وكانت قد وعدت في اليوم الاول
وبعد يومين تم تسهيل الامر للوصول الى
اللاذقيه ومن اجل اجراء عمليات تقييم
واسعه
وقد حصلنا على الضوء الاخضر
سؤال سريع لقد ذكرتم للتو ان عمليات الدعم
تلك قد تستمر لبضعه ايام فقط ما هي
الاشياء الاخرى التي هي
بامس التي هي مثل حاجه عليها وما هي اوجه
النقص الشديد في عمليه الغوص ثانيا عندما
تتحدثون عن ان الحكومه السوريه هي ليست
المشكله
وانها وعدت بتسهيل الامور بالنسبه لكم من
اجل تقديمي وتعزيزي الجهود الانسانيه هل
لديكم اي خطر في هذا الخصوص فهل لديكم
مثلا مساعدات انسانيه عبر الخطوط على
المدى القريب ويوم الامس الممثل الدائم
للحكومه الذريه قال ان بعض بعض
القوافل التي سوف تتوجه الى سوريا ليس
بمقدورها ان تحط في مطار دمشق هذا قد يكون
مشكله على بالنسبه للعمليات او المصادر
التي قد يجب التي يمكن ان تخصص لمساعده
الشعب السوري
سوف ابدا ومن ثم احيل الكلمه الى مهند
سوف ابدا بالوقوف على الاحتياجات
الاحتياجات هي المنطق هي المساله الحساسه
فنحن بحاجه الى غذاء وماء ومولدات لاننا
في اماكن قد لا توجد فيها مولدات الكهرباء
بالاضافه الى المساعدات الطبيه
[موسيقى]
علاجات للصدمات
النفسيه والحمايه بعد ذلك
اننا نعمل في بيئه
تعد هشه للغايه سلفا بحيث تفتق الى الوقود
والبنيه التحتيه تعاني وعانت كثيرا
والمنازل هناك
كانت تعاني منذ فتره طويله وقد يكون هناك
عمليات تهاوي لهذه المباني لذا فاننا
بحاجه الى معدات ازاله الانقاض البحث
واننا في في مكان يضرب فيه الشتاء البارد
لذا فهناك حاجه ماسه للبطانيات وكل ما
يخطر في بالكم عندما تكونوا في اوضاع صعبه
مشابهه
ولعل هناك نواحي اخرى مثل المساعدات
الطبيه اننا بحاجه لتسهيل هذه الاعمال هذه
منطقه مجددا
عانت معاناته من الصراع بين اطراف مختلفه
نحن نعمل هنا ونسعى للتنسيق بيني وبين
مهند
هو مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق شؤون
الانسانيه ومع المقر الرئيسي والوكالات
الاخرى المختلفه لاعطيكم مثالا حول ما حدث
اليوم وقد يكون هذا سؤالا وجيها اليوم
سوف يكون هناك وجود لمجموعه كبيره من
المنظمات الدوليه مثل
الصليب الاحمر الدولي
والمساله هي ليست نقص او معاناه في او شحف
المساعدات بل هي مساله تنسيق وسوف اجيب
اجيبك على مساله المده الزمنيه
برنامج الغذاء العالمي لديه ما يكفي
لاطعام مئات الالاف الاشخاص خلال اسبوع
اتحدث عن اسبوع من الزمن اما السؤال
الثاني
واذا ما كانت هذه الطائرات سوف يسمح لها
ان تحط في المطار قلت لكم واذكركم بان
الحكومه قد وعدت في بعض الاجتماعات بانها
سوف تسهل الامر لكن هذا السؤال يجب ان
يوجه مجددا الى الحكومه السوريه ولم نحصل
على اجابه حتى اللحظه مهند
نعم شكرا مصطفى لابد لي ان اقول ما هو
واضح
ومعروف لدى الجميع ان مساله تامين هذه
المساعدات والغوث هي مساله معقده معقده
حتى قبل
الزلزال فهي بحاجه الى مستويات متعدده من
التنسيق بين المنظمات الغير الحكوميه
والجهات المانحه وهي ليست عمليات مباشره
بالاضافه الى ذلك هذه المنطقه عسكريه
يتوجب علينا العمل بداخلها المساله ليست
يسيره كما قال مصطفى نعم الامم المتحده
لديها عزيمه والقدره على تنفيذ تلك المهمه
لكن الامر لا يتعلق فقط بالامم المتحده بل
يتعلق بالاطراف الاخرى التي يجب التنسيق
معها ونحن
لن نقوم
الا ببذل كافه الجهود المطلوبه لكن الكلام
اسهل من التنفيذ لك وفي ظل هذه الظروف
نستطيع ان نفعل المزيد عبر الخطوط وعبر
الحدود
شكرا
سؤال لكل من المتحدثين
ما هي الخطط الاوليه للامم المتحده في
مساله معالجه
الصدمات وتقديم المساعدات العاجله لانقاذ
حياه البشر في ظل
العقوبات التي فرضت على الحكومه السوريه
هذا السؤال الاول السؤال الثاني هل لكم
الارقام
الصحيحه عن اللقاحات التي سوف يتم تقديمها
في تلك المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره الحكومه
ان مصطفى لم يعد معنا
لا انا موجود مازلت
هناك ثلاثه اسئله
المساعدات المنقذه للحياه
واللقاحات والكوليرا بالنسبه للمساعدات
المنقذه للحياه فالامم المتحده لا تستطيع
ان تقدم الا ما تحصل عليه
الامر يعتمد على ما يصلنا وما سوف نقدم
تلك هي الاشياء التي يجب ان نطلبها هو ان
نسلط
الضوء على هذه الاحتياجات
وقد تكون مطلوبه حتى بعد 72 ساعه في عقابي
وقف في عمليات البحث والانقاذ في الانقاذ
المساله والاوضاع
التي نعاني منها
تنطوي على نقص الوقود قبل الحديث عن
العقوبات وغيرهم نحن لا يوجد لدينا
المعدات الكافيه واللازمه بحيث
يمكننا اصلاح بعض المعدات مثل
سيارات الاسعاف وغيرها
من المركبات
سوف نعمل على تامين كافه هذه المتطلبات
وسائل الاعلام يقع على كاهلها دور كبير في
مساعدتنا بدلا من الضجيج الذي نسمعه فانتم
شركاء لنا
العقوبات
جل ما استطيع ان اقوله ان هذه هي الاشياء
التي لدينا
فاننا بحاجه الى مولدات واننا بحاجه الى
اصلاح مضخات المياه والنضمن بان هناك
استثباب للامن
وبمقدورنا التحرك بسرعه من اجل تقديم
المساعده
نطلب منكم ان تساعدونا
لتحركي بسرعه وسوف نتحدث في مرحله لاحقه
عن السؤال الاكبر بالنسبه للعقوبات بشان
الكوليرا
اعتقد باننا حصلنا حتى اللحظه على مليونين
جرعه لقاحات
في
الشمال الشرقي
وفي المناطق الخاطئه لسيطره الحكومه
السوريه
وسوف نحصل على 1.6 مليون جرعه
لمناطق الواقعه في الشمال الغربي
هذا كان كله قبل الزلزال والان وبسبب
ذلك الزلزال وبسبب تجمع الناس في بعض
المناطق فان مصادر المياه قد تاثرت علمت
بان هذا قد اصاب بعض المناطق مثل حلب
واللاذقيه وغيرها لذا فاننا سوف نواجه هذا
الامر مجددا
المياه
التي قد تتاثر
وصرف الصحي في المناطق المكتظه
لذا قد نرى ازديا في حاله الكوليرا في هذه
المناطق لذا فاننا بحاجه للمزيد اننا
بحاجه لكل شيء من كل شخص